la jornada de este viernes en este
proceso ha sido especialmente larga pues
ha estado destinada a escuchar la
lectura del informe que el presidente de
esta corte especial
gianluigi ha hecho sobre los años de
investigaciones de los atentados del 13
de noviembre recordemos son más de 500
tomos comenzó con hechos muy objetivos
como la identidad de los diez atacantes
luego analizando la logística cómo se
radicalizaron como alquilaron los
departamentos donde se escondieron con
donde también prepararon algunos de los
explosivos cómo se movieron dentro de
parís esa noche pero lo más emocionante
ocurrió cuando el juez comenzó a
detallar los ataques de ese 13 de
noviembre en el stade francais las
terrazas y en la sala de conciertos
bataclán en cada uno de sus lugares él
dio los nombres la lista de fallecidos y
suciedades todos casi todos muy jóvenes
y ese momento provocó mucha emoción en
la gran sala del proceso pero también en
las otras en que la prensa sigue estas
audiencias mucha gente salió con los
ojos llorosos no fue fácil revivir
expedida que aún no se cierra en la
ciudad de parís yo converso con la madre
de un joven que falleció en la sala de
concierto para atacar a un joven chileno
está aquí su madre y su hermana ya
estaban muy emocionadas se escuchaban la
traducción justamente de lo que leía el
juez y sus asesoras escucharon solamente
el nombre de su hijo y de su hermano y
salieron de la sala porque sintieron que
no podían seguir soportando lo que
estaban escuchando